today we're going to be speaking with
chris smalls who is a former amazon
employee
who has become a leader of the
e-commerce
and labor rights movement chris is going
to tell us about his work for
and his subsequent firing from amazon
now of course we haven't been able to
independently
confirm uh chris's story
but it is a compelling one and i am more
than open
to having someone from amazon on to talk
to us
about the things that chris is going to
tell us uh chris
you have a background that started
similar to mine which is your background
is in retail i worked at the
now defunct circuit city when i
was much younger you worked at walmart
and target
uh but let's talk a little bit about
your work for uh for
amazon how did you come to work at
amazon
i started working at amazon back in
2015. i came in entry level
i came from before amazon i was working
at a grocery distribution warehouse
overnight
graveyard shift it was unionized but uh
the union contract just wasn't
uh what i expected it to be so i
thought that i have a better opportunity
at amazon i opened up the first building
in
carteret new jersey ewr9 uh
stayed there for about two years and
then i transferred to bdl2 connecticut
and then my last facility was jfka
staten island so i've been with the
company for almost four and a half years
and what was your day-to-day like what
kind of roles were you in
so when i became when i first got hired
i was entry level i was uh
what they call a picker uh i
my job was to pick customer items in a
timely manner
within the hour uh hourly rate of about
back then it was about 250 items an hour
now it's a lot more it's about 400 now
but i did that for about six to seven
months and then i was promoted up to a
process assistant
better known as an assistant manager and
i was in that position for the last four
years
now as an assistant manager were you
supervising pickers
yes i actually uh supervising pickers
uh and then it expanded to a different
operation
which now i was uh in control of three
different departments
so picking uh counting and also uh
um floor health so floor health was also
a part of the department as well
okay so many people in my audience have
probably seen
the articles that talk about the
conditions for the pickers and they
include things like
um you're not allowed to go to the
bathroom and there's this constant
pressure to pick more and more and more
and the conditions are bad and your
brakes are monitored down to the minute
talk a little bit about what what if
that was true
when you were there is any of it not
true
no it's 100 true amazon is ran
completely off of metrics and numbers
uh they calculate everything it is it's
actually calculated down to the second
you know the seconds you stop scanning
the item uh
your time accum accumulates a time off
task
so um i was a part of that machine i
very much had to monitor
my associates in my department but um
like i said i was just a supervisor that
related to them
so they respected the fact that i wasn't
that type of supervisor that would be
hard on them
if they came back late from break or
whatever the case may be because i know
uh how massive these buildings are and
how the working conditions can take a
toll on your body
now were you pressured even though you
weren't pressuring the pickers maybe the
way that you would be expected to did
that cause a problem for you
absolutely i mean um uh for the most
part
it caused a problem with my own personal
career growth because obviously
management
um knew that i would never side with
them when it came to certain things like
that
um you know i was kind of like the black
people of the uh supervisors
everybody knew that i had a backbone and
um i always spoke up for what was right
and i always sided with the employees at
entry level because that's where i
started from i never forgot where i came
from
and it didn't bother me but it
definitely hindered my career there
you know i applied for a salary manager
position there 49 times and i
i was denied every last one of them and
it's probably because the fact that they
knew
that i would never be fully uh pro
amazon
were you what reason were you given the
49 times why you weren't going to be
given the salary manager
well from my own personal experiences it
was
it was basically bogus um a lot of the
interviews were
set up for me to fail from the beginning
a lot of them the interviews they
already knew who they wanted in those
positions
uh before i even applied so it was a
combination of a lot of different things
um also there was uh you know letters
and
and management above me that didn't like
me as a person you know whatever the
case may be
so it was a lot of different things of
why um i didn't get those positions and
i believe it's systemic you know
systemic racism that
exists inside amazon as well over a
million and a half employees worldwide
and only and then 26 years of existence
only eight percent of the management is
black or brown
so that just tells you right there the
higher up the food chain the less likely
you know you are to be colored so
um i even believe this for the first
time this
past year they have one black woman
that's on the senior team
you know so that just tells you right
there the chances of me getting promoted
up
the ladder was slim and chris i don't
i'm not i'm not familiar with the
numbers you're citing so i'm curious
when you say eight percent
is that globally or in the united states
that's globally
that's globally okay do you know what it
is in the united states
i would guess it would be a lot less
than that you know i'm pretty sure
um it's not too many of us up at the top
you know once again
in this this company's 26 or 27 years of
existence
for the first time ever they put one
black woman on that the senior team
uh the s team they call it um so that
just tells you right there they're way
behind eight ball when it comes to
diversity
uh when it comes to management were
there ways in which
uh working at amazon was better than
when you did
actual customer facing retail like
walmart and target
of course you know i worked at
competitors and i worked
during the holiday season um and you
know
nothing's worse than working black
friday right at the time
you got customers trying to get their
items and and
the lines are backed up and everything's
chaos
chaos
so uh working in the warehouse um you
have to deal with customers
it's a benefit but um once again it's
also calisthenics you know so i used to
tell
my my employees new hires we have a gym
membership you might want to cancel it
[Laughter]
now um ultimately you you were fired by
amazon can you talk about why
yeah absolutely you know last year uh
the beginning of the pandemic
uh late february early march when this
virus
came into the country in seattle uh
killing the senior citizens over there i
i was afraid
over here in the east coast and i tried
to raise health and safety concerns
going through the proper channels
and after doing that for a few weeks i i
tried
organizing workers inside the warehouse
sitting in the cafeteria 10 hours a day
off the clock
i'm telling many as many workers as i
can after i learned in a meeting
with my bosses that uh we had cases in
the facility and they didn't want me to
tell
anybody not to cause a panic or disrupt
business um so i felt that i had to take
further action and after a whole week
of advocating i'm pleading and going
back and forth with the general manager
of the building
um they've decided to quarantine just me
other than everybody else and that
didn't make sense to me
not even the person i ride to work with
none of the people in my department that
was around the person who was infected
it was just me so i knew they were using
me as a target
and as a result i held the protest on
march 30th
outside of my facility and then two
hours later i was terminated over the
phone
a week after that uh jeff bezos and his
top general counsel
david sapolsky they tried to run a smear
campaign on me calling me not smart
articulate
and make me the whole face of the whole
unionizing efforts
so there's a couple different things
here right i mean the one is
that the part about infections at the
facility
and the other is trying to organize uh
the the the workers so let's talk about
the first one first
so you were told by by managers
not to talk about the fact that there
were infected employees
absolutely yes on march 24th we had an
uh
our daily sync meeting which we have
every single day and that's pretty much
giving us the rundown for the rest of
the day
and how it's supposed to go but on that
day it was different
uh that day they told us we had a case
that was actually two weeks prior
uh for the first time and they pretty
much told
the supervisors not to say anything and
i just felt that was
uh wrong i felt like i had to say
something that took my stance there that
was the last day i worked for amazon
so that was a supervisor's meeting and
you guys were told not to mention the
case to the employees you supervise
absolutely okay and then separately
but around the same time you were
working to organize the workers there
and what was the point of the
organization to approach management
about virus-related matters or to
collectively bargain on salary and
benefits
well actually that was the first time i
learned about it
i haven't even started organizing yet
that was march 24th
what i was doing was behind the scenes i
was sending out emails to the governor
to governor cuomo's office to the cdc
department
of manhattan media i was trying to fight
behind the scenes uh
it wasn't until after that meeting the
next day when i came back to the
facility
um i told my supervisor i won't be
working for the remain of the week
and that's when i started to go in the
cafeteria and tell all the workers that
i
came in contact with the truth that you
possibly been
working around somebody who tested
positive um from that point forward
what we did every morning uh a small
group of us
marched into the general manager's
office and voice our concerns
yeah uh has this thing called uh voice
of associates
where associates are allowed to write on
the board uh their complaints
so i said you know what here is your
your voice over
associates board uh right here in person
uh here's our complaints we wanted the
building to just be simply closed down
and sanitized we would have came back to
work no problem and that's all we wanted
in the beginning but obviously a lot
more
now what was officially given to you as
the reason why you were being let go
oh they claimed that i violated socially
this is policies that
none of us ever read are ever you know
implemented you know
as a supervisor i'm supposed to receive
the policies and relay
that information that i never did so
they didn't exist because
they didn't know what we were dealing
with you know and that's all
um it was okay to understand that they
didn't know what they were dealing with
how to
handle it but uh to ignore the fact that
workers
with underlying health conditions you
know mothers that were pregnant
uh parents that have children at home
including myself
were afraid to come to work and refuse
to listen to us that's a whole nother
story
when it comes to what you're fighting
for now if i understand correctly
you're looking to organize uh sort of a
non-union nationwide group of workers am
i right that you're going the non-union
approach and what made you decide to go
about it that way
um yeah you know i i feel like with
amazon there's such a large
entity in a large business that uh
you know it actually would be kind of
difficult for one union to try to
unionize the entire nation uh we're
talking 800 000 workers
so i felt like an organization that has
a worker
driven committee would be more
beneficial for amazon workers uh
something that's working employee
controlled uh but union-like structure
you know i feel like that's the best way
possible it's sort of like cutting down
the middleman
uh no you know no union duels or
whatever the case may be
but workers are allowed to sit in on
negotiation negotiate their own
contracts
and then now we all we also have enough
power
um workers power that if congress said
you know you're an essential worker
and you have to go to work in the middle
of a pandemic right we're going to say
no
we're not going to work until we have
you know
a ppe provided by the company hazard pay
medical leave all these things that
we're demanding
before we consider ourselves essential
workers so that's interesting
so absent the action the the actual
union with the dues
sort of like at what level would you see
this working would it be at the
individual facility level would be at a
regional level or how do you how would
you structure that yeah you know i
thought about it and i think uh
regional would be better um if you had
just one
you know you break down the country into
regions you have a committee
a workplace committee that represents
that region
because we know the cost of living in
different parts of the country is
different
these committees negotiate the contract
and there you go
uh that be able to you know take care of
the mass of the employees that work for
amazon
with unionizing you have to do a
facility by facility
and that's going to be a longer process
as you can see what they're doing in
alabama
they're prolonging it the union busting
yeah um they're firing workers they're
hiring workers
they're doing all these things to
disrupt it uh but if you have a
workplace committee that's something
that's built internally
uh it's gonna be hard to uh bust that up
did you ever see or experience
um or become aware of sort of like not
union busting but maybe union prevention
activity by amazon absolutely
as a supervisor you know i watched uh
you know those training videos we had to
take tests assessment tests
they try to mix in uh certain questions
that
obviously related to union busting but
um i never applied them you know like i
said i was
i'm always uh on the employee entry
level position side so
i never applied these things you know
obviously there was management that
though
that you know applied that and they
still do
um but you know you just have to
understand what you're dealing with
you're dealing with a company that does
that's anti-union
from the beginning and now we see that
it's very much
necessary that they are unionized yeah i
remember
in my early days at circuit city they
sat me down and mixed in with training
videos about like how to use the sales
systems
and what the process is for requesting
time off they throw in videos about
you know we want to maintain a direct
relationship with employees we don't
want any intermediaries or middlemen and
it was very
it was very sophisticated in fact the
way that it was done
oh yeah yeah the same thing you know uh
they mixing
the questions with like safety and
hazmat and all this training and i'm
like well
you know you read between the lines
you're right yeah
uh we've been speaking with chris smalls
former amazon employee now a leader of
the e-commerce labor rights movement
chris i really appreciate your time and
we're going to continue following your
great work
absolutely i appreciate you guys for
giving me a chance to tell my story